yo what's cracking this your homeboy Ice
Cube and this is the wired auto complete
interview
[Music]
man give me them damn questions what you
asking me
cinnamon
who played Ice Cube in Straight Out of
Compton still young y'all pretty boy
name
I think his name is O'Shea Jackson the
third he did a great job but he ain't
nothing like his daddy who is Ice Cube's
best friend my best friend is my wife
Kim best friend I ever had what would
Kevin Hart say Kevin Hart wouldn't say
nothing Kevin no he's not my best friend
Kevin is the friend that owes me the
most money who was Ice Cube's producer
depends you know you talking about the
one and only Dr Dre you know I have been
produced by the one and only Dr Dre who
is Ice Cube related to well you know I'm
related to a few people it's a rapper by
the name Adele the Funky Homosapien if
you didn't know that was my little
cutting that's my little cutting I'm
also related to a guy named Max Shawn
you know I mean 100 and I do know that
okay let's see here is Ice Cube a Raider
fan come on man you know the answer to
that I'm the president of the Raider
Nation Tom Brady you're rookie we need
donuts in the locker room bruh it's Ice
Cube coming out with another Friday
hopefully but you never know you know
it's not in my hands if it was in my
hands we'd be on the 20th version it'll
be like Fast and Furious it's Ice Cube
East or West Coast West Coast baby I am
the West Coast warlord is Ice Cube from
Compton or South Central see now this
might trip you up if you don't know you
hear Straight Out of Compton and you
didn't know Ice Cube was from South
Central is Ice Cube old school rap no
I'm not old school rap I'm every school
rappers every school
next what is Ice Cube Big Three The Big
Three is the best professional three on
three league in in the world we on to
season six All Summer Long baby we bring
in the fire what is Ice Cube's best
album how could you pick just one that's
like asking me what's my best kid all of
them what is Ice Cube's diet Pizza Fat
Burgers I love a good steak ribeye I
might stop you know I mean at the at the
cabinet and grab a snack what is Ice
Cube's good day man it's a good day when
I'm kicking it and nothing bad happened
to my family my friends or anybody I
know that is a good day yeah it's a
little different now you know I'm a
married man you know what I'm saying I
can't be doing the things I did in that
song man what does Ice Cube look like
now handsome as ever
three bam does Ice Cube do meet and
greets yes I do I love to meet the fans
and everybody know a lot of kids okay
does Ice Cube like corn you talking
about the band of course I like corn
come on man you know one of the best
bands to come out of La baby corn my
partner Jeff quantness used to manage
corn we ran into each other and it was
just a good vibe we did music together
went on a family event values tour with
them friends to this day does Ice Cube
live in Anaconda how can I live in
Anaconda oh did I live in the movie
Anaconda I was like man how can I live
in an anaconda yes Ice Cube did live in
Anaconda since I'm the black guy you
probably thought I'd Die early in the
movie like in Jurassic Park thank you
Steven Spielberg does Ice Cube own his
Masters yes I do
ah how old was Ice Cube in Boyz in the
Hood 19. when did Ice Cube get famous my
breakout hit was a song that I did
called dope man Dopeman produced by Dr
Dre put out on Rufus records we dropped
it in uh 87. ice cubes Ninja Turtles
what about my Ninja Turtles I'm playing
Superfly the baddest villain since Darth
Vader the baddest villain since Jaws
don't get on this bad side he'll on
you how did Ice Cube and Dr Dre meet I
met Dr Dre because his cousin lived
right down the street from me I was
always waiting for him to come over he
came over I rap for him the rest is
history
Q
Bow Down lyrics The world is mine homie
get back don't mess with my stack the
gauges rack about to drop the bomb I'm
that dime big fish in a
small pond you know the rest Ice Cube
first song is it the first hit song or
just the first song I ever wrote Because
the first song I wrote was kind of it
was boo-boo it was uh a few years of
rapping I started rapping when I was 14.
I wrote a song for The Wrecking Crew
when I was 15. there's a song called the
Cabbage Patch dance it was you know my
first song written very proud of it and
then I wrote Boyz in the Hood when I was
16. ice cubes yay George Clinton
actually got it off of uh Knee Deep
record he say yeah yeah not just needed
as long as they did when she did the
freak with me that's where the yay comes
from George Clinton Ice Cube's eyebrow
it is
that was ice cubes wired Auto
um
complete interview complete interview
yay yay see you next time